welcome to the Earth's atmosphere it's
kind of weird near the surface the air
is pretty warm but the higher up you go
the cooler it gets surely this trend
just carries on forever oh my God these
are the two lowest layers of the
atmosphere the troposphere and the
stratosphere we'll explain why this guy
thinks it's okay to do this in a little
bit and also why the stratosphere proves
that the sun cannot be behind recent
global warming you may think that the
atmosphere is heated by the Sun but you
shouldn't think that because you'd be a
silly goose the atmosphere is heated
From Below by the Earth which is heated
by the Sun so I guess you're kind of
right but you may ask where does the
Earth get heated by the Sun but the
atmosphere doesn't well that's a great
question my copy of firmament the
perfect introductory book to atmospheric
physics the reason is that light comes
in different wavelengths and different
substances absorb certain wavelengths
but not others this folder for example
appears orange when I shine a white
light through it because it absorbs all
the wavelengths apart from the ones that
we call Orange sunlight is mostly made
of short wavelengths of light and the
atmosphere just doesn't care about short
wavelengths so they don't get absorbed
there they just go right through and get
absorbed instead by the earth below
which absorbs all the light that shines
on it because it's you know opaque
because it has a temperature
yep the Earth gives off light of its own
which we call thermal radiation but
because it's so much cooler than the sun
yep the light it gives off is less
energetic which translates to being
longer wavelengths so sunlight short
wavelengths Earth lights long
wavelengths the planet emits its long
wavelength thermal radiation up into the
atmosphere and this is where things get
more complicated because while the
atmosphere may be chill in letting short
wavelengths of light through it it is
absolutely not chill about long
wavelengths so the bottom part of the
atmosphere absorbs the Earth's thermal
radiation which causes it to warm up but
it has a temperature of its own as well
so it emits thermal radiation just a
little bit less than the planet below
and some of that radiation goes upwards
into the rest of the atmosphere and some
of it goes downwards back towards the
planet the bit that goes upwards is
attenuated by subsequent layers it goes
downwards
I think we need a computer breaking the
atmosphere into vertical called chunks
we can simulate this with a gray or gray
radiation model the vertical axis here
is the logarithm of air pressure which
is roughly equivalent to altitude and
the color represents the air temperature
in each Chunk in each chunk of the
atmosphere we calculate the upward and
downward long wavelength radiation which
is fed by the short wavelength radiation
from the Sun that passes straight
through the atmosphere and warms the
planet below the result is that the
temperature of the surface is determined
in part by the radiation coming in from
the Sun and in part by how the
atmosphere exchanges long wavelength
radiation with itself and the surface
the further away from the surface you go
the less thermal energy is available and
so the temperature of the atmosphere
decreases but what about the
stratosphere it gets warmer with
altitude well remember when I said that
the atmosphere just doesn't care about
short wavelengths the atmosphere just
doesn't care about short wavelengths
like that I was overlooking one molecule
ozone it absorbs shortwave legs of light
and when it does so it warms up and
where do you find ozone bam the heating
provided by the ozone layer absorbing
short wavelength radiation is enough to
overcome the cooling effect of being
further away from the surface and it's
what creates the stratosphere now I love
the stratosphere it's so great I spent
four years of my life crying over it but
it also gives us the clearest evidence
of what is behind the climate crisis
because what's the atmosphere been doing
recently it's been warming up not
everywhere while the troposphere are bit
of the atmosphere has been warming up as
you can see in the famous warming
Stripes graphic over the same time
period the stratosphere has actually
been cooling down now what could be
causing that
foreign
in the stratosphere that would cause
less stratospheric Heating and so would
make the stratosphere cool down and
humans have been depleting the ozone
layer for decades now though it's
actually starting to recover thanks
Montreal protocol so it's a factor but
not enough to explain the observed
cooling what if though hear me out the
same thing is causing the troposphere to
warm up and the stratosphere to cool
down I'm not crazy I'm not crazy the
temperature of the Earth's surface is
partly determined by the amount of
sunlight coming in and partly by how the
atmosphere traps long wavelength
radiation so hypothesis one the
troposphere is warming because the
amount of sunlight coming in has
increased on hypothesis 2 the
troposphere is warmed because the
atmospheres got better at absorbing long
wavelength radiation
foreign
and water vapor and methane and a few
others but CO2 is the important one
let's go back to our gray or gray
radiation model we'll run three
simulations the first will be the
atmosphere with nothing changed this
will be our Baseline in the second
simulation we'll dial up the short
wavelength radiation coming in from the
Sun and in the third simulation we'll
increase the CO2 concentration of the
atmosphere which we do by increasing the
optical depth to make the results easier
to see we'll look at the results of the
last two minus the result of the first
one the Baseline so we can see the
change in temperatures through the
atmosphere caused by our alterations to
the simulation hypothesis one by
increasing the shortwave thanks
radiation coming in from the sun the
planet heats up as does the atmosphere
most intensely close to the surface but
also up in the stratosphere this is
partly because of heating from the
surface and partly because of extra
ozone Heating
two by increasing how effectively the
atmosphere absorbs long wavelength
radiation close to the surface it heats
up but up in the stratosphere the air
almost immediately cools down
the reason this happens is that by
making the atmosphere more efficient at
absorbing long wavelengths of thermal
radiation it doesn't reach the
stratosphere it all gets absorbed by the
troposphere and so less radiation coming
in from below but the same amount
leaving out into space
means the stratosphere cools down
there's also a more subtle cause to do
with the extra CO2 molecules in the
stratosphere getting excited by
collisions and then radiating the extra
energy out to space I'll leave a link
down there if you want to online
tropospheric warming on its own could be
explained by either more sunlight
arriving or by the increase in
concentrations of gases that absorb long
wavelength radiation like carbon dioxide
the stratosphere cooling at the same
time however rules out the Sun as an
explanation so as well as being weird
and generally delightful the
stratosphere gives us a really clear
message about why the temperature down
here is going up it's not the Sun
it's us so to a particular breed of
climate skeptic I say shut up
son
study of atmospheric physics involves
both physical equations and controlling
the Demons Inside electrified sand but
what if I told you there was a website
and companion app that allowed you to
learn both at the same time in a fun
interactive way
well that's brilliant to have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant has
courses across a range of subjects in
science maths and computer science at
levels from middle school to graduate
school in this video I drew on Concepts
covered in their courses on waves and
light and physics of the everyday and
program this visualization using python
which you can learn in their dedicated
course on the subject all the courses
are written by experts and emphasize
trying out the concepts yourself using
interactive exercises this is an
entirely different world from just
reading a textbook and then
regurgitating it you're mastering not
memorizing 10 million people have signed
up for brilliant and they've been
leaving it some Stellar reviews and
that's no surprise brilliant is a
perfect companion to learning in a
classroom setting I'm a school child
using brilliant on my laptop but also a
resource for people who have left
full-time education but want to keep
learning and improve their
problem-solving skills I'm old and using
the app to join them and sign up for
free head to brilliant.org Simon Clark
and the first 200 people to sign up to a
premium subscription with that link will
get 20 percent off that's brilliant.org
Simon Clark who continued to show their
excellent taste by supporting this
channel
thank you so much for watching the video
in case you couldn't tell had a bit of
fun making this one if you'd like to
learn more about atmospheric physics
then as I said earlier I can highly
recommend firmament but if you'd like to
watch something then here's some videos
from me that just leads me to say thank
you very much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'll see you in the next one